- Hi, I'm Rie.
I'm a Tasty producer.
Today, I'm making a
dish without any trash.
I don't know what is the dish yet.
It's gonna be a surprise,
and I don't like surprise.
You know, in a daily
life when you're cooking,
you're making a lot of
trash without noticing.
In the kitchen, I use
a lot of saran wraps,
plastic containers.
I feel like I should be
more conscious about it.
We make a lot of trash,
and where does it go?
What's this?
Apple pie?
Apple has cores and stem.
So, apple pie.
We will need flour, butter, apples,
cinnamon powder, and sugar.
Most of the dry ingredients
come in a package,
so I hope we can find a grocery store
that has bulk section so I
can bring my own containers.
(laughs) This look like
potato, let's do potato pie.
So, this was my first time
going to the grocery store
with bulk section.
Less trash is still trash.
Trash, trash (laughs).
And we got little bit
cinnamon in a giant jar.
I've got Granny Smith apples.
It has sticker on it, so sad.
I just remembered I made this
beautiful rose apple pie for Tasty,
and I can use apple skin.
That's kind of bummer
because I chose green apple.
I should have chose red apple.
That's why I don't like surprises.
I'm still figuring out how to use core.
Maybe I'm gonna just eat them.
I'll sacrifice myself for
this challenge (laughs).
Making pie.
Now, we're gonna make a pie crust.
Alright, quarter cup of sugar,
two and a quarter cup of
flour, and now butter.
You wanna use cold butter
and cut into small pieces.
This is the butter with least
amount of trash we could find.
Trash in a bowl.
Okay, I'm gonna use this bowl scraper
to make butter small pieces.
Okay, and now I'm adding the
ice water in a pie dough.
I love making pie.
It's something very calming about it.
My pie dough is almost done, and usually,
you have to wrap with saran wrap.
Saran wrap is also waste,
so I think if I have a container with lid,
it's gonna totally do the job.
I'm gonna wash my hands.
(water running)
Peeling the stickers.
It's kind of sad.
After that, I'm gonna wash this
apple and slice them thinly.
Struggles.
I'm gonna make a separate waste,
like food waste and trash.
But you know, the taste will be good.
Very tart.
This apple is very slippery.
The rose apple pie I
made was without peel.
So, what if it doesn't work?
I'm going to macerate with sugar.
Half cup of sugar, half
cup of brown sugar,
but we don't have it.
Cinnamon.
Okay, and leave this another 30 minutes
so it's gonna get soft.
Alright, so my pie dough
is chilled for 30 minute,
and I'm going to roll out this dough.
Sprinkle flour on the surface.
I think it's a good size.
So, I'm going to prick...
Do you say prick?
Prick the dough so it doesn't puff up.
We have this apple macerated.
I have leftover juice, and
I'm going to boil it down,
make a syrup, and I can top with that.
It's not that much, and
I'm gonna grab a spatula.
Oh, no, if it burned...
Oh, okay.
No waste.
(crunching)
Okay, so I have a leftover dough.
What kind of pattern should I make?
Leaf, maybe?
Usually, you stick with egg wash.
You know, if I use egg, there
will be egg shell, egg carton,
so I'm gonna just put water
and hope for the best.
I feel pretty good about
the amount of waste I made.
I don't wanna speak too soon.
So, I have some leftover dough.
What about if I make pie, pie.
I use all dough, yay!
So, I got this silicon mat you
can use as a parchment paper.
Pie.
So, I'm gonna go bake in the oven.
Bye!
40 minute.
Ta da!
Pie.
I think I did great.
It was hard, but it's totally doable.
When I started, I was 50% confident,
but I made this beautiful pie
and I'm pretty feel good about it,
both my pie and the
amount of trash I created.
So, I think we should be more conscious
about how much trash we
are making in daily life.
If you are more conscious
about what you choose,
you can totally make less waste.
So, I'm going to share
this with my coworkers,
and let's see what they think.
- Wow!
- Those look like sausages.
- It looks pretty!
- I had to make this pie
without making any waste,
and this is the amount of trash I created.
- Oh!
- Nice.
(all talking)
- And you folded it?
- You could eat that.
- I can compost the core after I eat it.
- Do we eat?
- Yeah, please.
(laughing)
- Fantastic.
- Also, doesn't it taste better
knowing that hardly any trash was created?
I'm actually really impressed
because I have not tried to
make something this ambitious,
but you've inspired me.
- This is so good.
- Simple, tasty, delicious.
- Tasty, no wastey.
- [Nikki] There's nothing else to say.
Tasty, no wastey.
(laughing)